yet when ODS as you know is hello or
g'day in Spanish you see this picture of
me there I'm not a matador but I love
learning languages and I have my own
experience about learning languages and
that's what I want to share with you
today particularly as it applies to
Spanish now while we whoops I wasn't
right now while we while I talk you can
send in any questions you may have
you can send them in by Twitter and I
will try to reply to them either during
the webinar or after the webinar so I'm
going to speak for about 30 minutes
using these slides and then we're going
to have 30 minutes or however much time
you need to answer questions that you
may have and you can ask your questions
in different languages if you want all
right now I always say and you if you
watch my videos you'll know that to me
there are three key elements in language
learning one is your attitude towards
the language which is the most important
not only for the language but towards
the whole process of learn and so the
first question has to be why learn
Spanish because if you're not interested
in Spanish if you don't want to learn
Spanish you're probably not going to
succeed so Spanish to me is one of the
most useful and fun languages to learn
it's widely spoken throughout Latin
America obviously in Spain it's your
first access to the Latins of the
Romance languages it's easy to learn now
let's be a little bit careful with this
to really speak it well it's not easy
but it's written the way it's pronounced
there's a lot of vocabulary in common
with English so it's relatively easy and
of course it uses a lot of out of it so
if your language uses the Latin outfit
is easy for you Spanish could be your
first second language makes you
bilingual and if you do that you can
learn a third language
and Spanish is associated with music and
dance and Sun and so forth and the
cultures vary from Mexico to Peru to
Argentina to Spain as I said it's easy
to read and you can a lot of people
travel to spanish-speaking countries
whether it be Spain or Mexico or or
wherever and particularly if you live in
the state the United States Spanish can
help you get a job because the Spanish
speakers are a significant market in the
United States and research shows that
learning another language is good for
the brain so there's lots of good
reasons to learn Spanish now again if
you've been following my videos you know
that's the fastest and most painless and
least expensive way to acquire the
vocabulary you need and to become
familiar with the language it's a read
and listen when I study languages I
mostly listen but it's read also an hour
an hour and a half a day it gives my
brain a chance to get used to the
language it allows me to notice things
so it's very very important that you
devote most of your time to reading and
listening but listen to things that you
like listen to things that you find
meaningful and interesting and so one of
my objectives today is to show you how
you can quickly move to things of
interest so you aren't constantly
reading boring textbook type material so
you eventually should choose what you
want to listen to or read now Spanish is
written the way it's pronounced there's
a few column different little usages
that you may not be familiar with in
your own language like the Double L in
PI a guy's not Paola is PI ADA okay and
the end with a tilde on top as in espana
or Pina Colada but these are things
you're going to get used to very quickly
I've learned Chinese and Russian and
Japanese with very different scripts
Spanish is relatively easy one
interesting things like which ever
accent you choose to copy it really
doesn't matter in Spain say Tokyo Garcia
the CI is pronounced like a th in
English but in Latin America is
pronounced got si
other than that the vowel sounds are
relatively constant in Spanish unlike
English where you go from Australian to
British to u.s. South to Boston
in Spanish the basic pronunciation of
the vowel sounds is the same but there
are some differences and you should just
choose whichever pronunciation you
prefer but I when I listen and read I
might read material from Latin America
from Spain from Mexico from Argentina it
doesn't matter
mostly I'm motivated by my interest in
what I'm listening to and read and
you've got to pay attention alright so
in in English qu is qwop but in Spanish
qu is like a que quiero una cerveza okay
whereas the qua sound is which is
written with a Cu quad okay and I saw
like the song okay
the H isn't pronounced so its hasta
LaVista
right and the are people worried about
the R and particularly if it's a double
or it's all very it's a trilled
are petrol you can go you know five
hours if you want and if they are is at
the beginning of the word is Rahman it's
a heavy are a lot of people get worried
about this are my advice is get used to
the language get used to listening to it
notice it and slowly start practicing
letting the tip of your tongue kind of
roll against the bottom of your against
your column all right wouldn't worry
about it okay similarly for example V
and B are pronounced essentially the
same and those are the kinds of things
that you should start to notice when
you're listening to the language alright
and the Spanish when you're reading they
use punctuation and accents differently
than we do so every question has a
interrogation or a question mark at the
beginning beginning and at the end and
in a variety of situations often for
questions and to change the intonation
of a word you'll see an accent so don't
try and remember any of this stuff just
start noticing that these things happen
in the lab okay
to me language learning is not about
intelligence it's not like I'll give you
an example I read a very interesting
book by a very intelligent person who
describes called red alert
it describes his experiences in Russia
very intelligent person lived there for
10 years not only can't speak Russian he
can't pronounce the names of Russian
people
so intelligence doesn't equal success in
language learning developing the ability
to notice what's happening in the
language is the key all right and you
then train your brain and that's what
I'm going to talk about today is how we
can notice things and how we can develop
you know how we can train the brain for
notice and through noticing then these
new aspects this different ways of
expressing things start to become part
of our natural process in the brain all
right so I'm gonna start with what I
call the 12 core patterns all right now
step back I always say the key is to
listen and read and to focus on things
of interest to you alright so in the
case of Spanish my interests are in
history and literature I have lots of
material some of which is in our library
at length which I like to listen to and
read the key for me is that I'm
motivated by my interest in the content
and I'm not consciously trying to learn
the language I'm just letting the
language wash over me at length I'm
saving words and phrases that then are
highlighted in yellow and through my
interest in the subject matter
I am acquiring the language however
however there are things that we can do
that will help us notice patterns in the
language better one of these things is
to work on sort of a selection of
sentences which focus on a particular
pattern so in the 12
our pattern here I'm going to talk about
twelve what I consider to be basic
concepts that every language has to
express and if I then make another
webinar on German or Japanese or Chinese
or Russian then I will talk about these
same core patterns and how they are
dealt with in other languages but today
I'm going to talk about how they're
dealt with in Spanish and once we've got
the core patterns work I'll go back a
bit here so in other words things and
people verb what what kind where who's
to whom for whom and sever how how many
which who okay whenever when and then
the whole issue of tenses so that's what
we're going to look but you know spend a
little more time on but once you got the
basic patterns down now we want to
express certain concepts we want to
expect express the idea of probability
maybe my should possibility is such as
well there's a bunch of expressions that
relate to that and I should say we have
prepared in link and I'll get to this
later lessons with ten or fifteen or
twenty sentences for each of these
categories and that is for you to go to
not once but ten times go to it as an
early stage in your learning go to it
later on internet and again and again to
refresh your ability to focus on certain
specific aspects of the language so
probability what if reason or purpose
opinions like how do you think like in
my opinion I think it seems to me
feelings and then of course connector
words like therefore although on the
other hand and so forth and that the
other the third part of the sort of
training the brains focus is going to be
certain key words or trigger words that
again help us express our thoughts
marketing so those are kind of the three
different types of patterns that we want
to get at but let's now move along to
the first one in our basic patterns
which
things and people in Spanish the nouns
have gender masculine and feminine
alright so those of you who are new to
Spanish is important those of you who
are already advanced in Spanish you know
this and it's fairly consistent in other
words a any amount that end in it I
can't say any but most nouns that end in
a are feminine most nouns that ended
da-ad Universidad or IOM la conversación
are going to be feminine whereas nouns
that end in O are going to be masculine
and the plural is formed by adding an S
pretty straightforward and you'll find
in our link library and if you're linked
to this later on a bunch of drills where
you can kind of concentrate on that
don't worry about remembering it all the
time
what you want to develop is that ability
to notice and almost automatically if
you start noticing oh yeah that's a
masculine essence eminence you're going
to gradually start doing it
automatically alright so that's and the
other thing about Spanish is they have
articles because not every language has
articles but in Spanish just as in
English there are articles okay there is
the LA or una or el at une or loss all
right verbs verbs is the big bugbear for
everybody studying Spanish because quite
frankly the verbs in Spanish do present
a degree of complexity greater than many
of the languages that I studied in more
complex than Japanese and Chinese then
then a number of languages so you can
you can look at these tables as much as
you want
you're not done in my experience I
cannot remember verb endings just by
study diggle's but you can start
noticing so first of all you'll notice
that the verb endings changed depending
on whether it's I or you or he so it
changes for every what we call person
and for that reason very often in
they don't include the first person
because in English if I say I go if I
just say go you don't know if it I go
you go they go you don't know but in
Spanish you know and so very often you
simply see the verb with no personal
pronoun alright another thing to start
noticing is that amongst the so called
regular verbs there are three groups the
ar verbs the ER verb and the IR verbs
now don't try to remember anything but
do remember this anytime you need to
know how a verb is conjugated or
anything to do with verbs or anything
else in Spanish you just google the
resources available on the internet for
language learning are stupendous you can
download grammars you can download
tables you can get any verb conjugated
and I frequently refer to Google when in
doubt whether it be in Spanish or even a
you know Romanian but the resources for
Spanish are just phenomenal so do make
use of Google as a reference but again
are you emphasize again don't spend all
your time studying tables it's a
relatively low product you know
ineffective thing to spend your time on
spend most of your time listening and
reading alright in every language you
want to say what okay okay I say so what
is that okay so I'm not gonna give you
any rules but you have to become
familiar with the fact and notice the
fact that again what do we see we see an
upside down question mark at the
beginning of every question we see that
the question words have an accent so
just noticing these things or we see in
que kidding what do you want there's no
personal pronoun there it just kicks it
what do you want we know it's get it
because it's the verb ending tells you
that it's the second person singular so
again there's lots of drills now that we
put into the link library who you can go
and concentrate on this expression of
what left how do I say what because
you're going to find that at various
times in your language study you're
going to have trouble expressing some of
these basic con
when you do you should go back again to
either our lessons in link or some other
place and drill yourself on some of
these patterns the best grammar book is
one which has lots of examples and very
few explanations because our ability to
learn through repeating examples
concentrated a concentrated collection
of example is far greater than our
ability to understand explanations all
right so that's the what what kind and
here we get to this whole question of KT
boy is what time but we have adjectives
and what we have to start noticing here
is that in most cases in Spanish the
adjective comes after the noun don't
remember it just starts noticing where
it shows up and the other thing we have
to notice is that if we have lost
Chico's Altos the adjective agrees with
the now okay these are grammatical terms
but every time we say a Chico is outdoor
if it's lost chickens its los chicos
outpost so you know la casa is a house
la casa blanca Blanca has to agree with
Casa whereas une grande coach it and
here we have the exception where
sometimes the adjective comes before so
don't worry about it just start noticing
the agreement of adjectives and their
position alright then we have to compare
things
so here again L is much grand occasion
remember the double L is like a pipe my
grande lumic rounded up biggest lammeter
mosa
and remember the H isn't pronounced
llama or mosa so these are all you're
going to see them in the sample drills
and you can gradually get used to it
similarly you know this that those you
have to pay attention to when it si kata
aquellos over there s up here esta here
and again but I'm trying to remember get
used to these patterns where again you
know donde is if the
to where and you have to get used and
you'll go to our drills and practice
they're here above below etc all right
and the whole question of this is
handled differently in different
languages you know for Kim Dobin unless
Campanas For Whom the Bell Tolls right
to whom is the car whose car is this all
of these things you're going to be able
to practice when you go to our lessons
and I'll give you a link to it later on
how is Komal and can we start how are
you kamusta again by now you're noticing
and I'm I apologize as some of you are
already advanced in Spanish but I'm
trying to cover it all so people who may
be looking at learning Spanish for the
first time and so you have again the
upside-down question mark you have an
accident on koh mook is it's a question
word and of course it's us has an
accident because normally without that
accident it would be active and so these
are the kinds of things that you're
slowly going to get used to and here
you'll focus on how to express the
concept of how and how many now one
thing about numbers I find it very
difficult to learn numbers many grammar
books will give you numbers up front and
I just find it so difficult because
numbers are so high hardwired in my own
language that is very difficult they
quickly get used to saying numbers in a
different language but in this section
when you go to our lessons you'll be
able to see many of these expressions
that have to do with the issue of
quantity and who is interested like the
man who lives in this house the woman
that I love you know the woman with whom
I'm speaking these are all the total
relative pronoun concept which exist in
every language dealt with differently in
each language and this is again a
concept but you should regularly refresh
yourself on make sure you really nail
this down all right similarly for the
concept of whichever whenever whatever
this is the concept that you have to
work on and
all these these expressions of time that
will normally trigger one tense or
another and you should definitely focus
on quando is when simply always order
now nunca normalmente a until this which
is it these are expressions that you
can't remember them all at once but you
can drill yourself regularly to get a
sense of expressing when alright and
this is the last of these slides and you
know what shouldn't be scared by Spanish
tenses it's something you're going to
learn but you're not going to learn it
overnight you're not going to look at
the table that we put here on the screen
and be able to memorize all these in is
just not going to happen
you're not going to immediately
understand when the imperfect is used or
the conditional or the subjunctive is
not going to happen
however by training yourself with these
concentrated as sentences and then when
you are reading and listening trying to
notice trying to pay attention to how
these verbs are used you will gradually
train the brain so we have by the way in
our library a lesson that was created
for us by one of our members from
Barcelona I'll bet it and it's called
punto de vista and there's 19 lessons
and he tells essentially the same story
nineteen different ways using different
tenses subjunctive and so forth and so
on so that the core vocabulary remains
the same the story is the same but the
tenses change and this is an example of
a kind of concentrated listening that
you can do that's going to help you to
notice however you know we can't listen
to the same thing over and over again
it's important if we talk about training
the brain we need to alternate between
novelty and repetition if you only give
to print the brain repetition the brain
is going to turn
the second third fourth fifth time you
are no longer learning here there's a
definite law of diminishing returns so
you have to have a balance between
concentrated repetition and interesting
things and I believe that the balance
should be 80% interesting things
exposure to the language where you're
trying to notice and then occasionally
going to the sort of repetitious
exercises where you're kind of kind of
focused and overworked as if we were
working out overwork certain muscles
focus and the reason I've set out these
twelve areas here twelve basic concepts
is that I want you to go to one at a
time don't do all twelve go to one of
them there's a good 10 15 20 sentences
in each of these 12 concept areas go
there and work that one area work the
one where you feel you have difficulty
and then go back to spending most of
your time enjoyably hopeless listening
it reads so just - I've mentioned these
lessons in our link library and I'll
leave you with the link to them but when
you go into a lesson like this is
category 12 here temples are ballast is
pensive and we've got a bunch of lessons
a bunch of the example sentences and if
you go here you can see you click on
this which is our resources section
every lesson in link has resources
behind it it could be a translation it
could be notes or whether I should say
every but many of them do you click
there and it's going to open up this
translation to English and if you then
go you will see that in the translation
section for each of these training
exercises and we're using this symbol
the focus symbol because this is where
you're going to focus on a particular
concept for each one of these we've set
up basically what some people call
interlinear translation and other as
each sentence appears in the translation
section with the English underneath it
so that even if you don't understand as
you're listening what you want to do is
focus on one aspect so here we're
focusing on tenth so to hermana wave
Akane pelota so you're going to focus on
that's the present tense in fact all of
these in the first section are in the
present as is indicated on the right
hand side and what I want people to do
if they're at that you can go in and
save the odd word that you don't know if
you're a beginner you may be overwhelmed
by the amount of new vocabulary don't
worry about it just make it a bit of an
experience see what you can notice even
if you notice something on every third
sense it's giving you a little bit of
exposure to the language you go back and
use one of our many beginner lessons
that link or other material as you may
have and then go back again and you'll
see that you'll understand more and more
of this so depending on your level in
the language this might be an
introduction to these basic concepts or
it might be a chance to focus on one of
them where you're having difficulty or
simply to refresh and and sort of feel
even more confident in your ability to
to use these tenses or expressions
accurately so I think I've spoken long
enough again this is the new experience
for me I don't know if people have
questions I'm not entirely sure how I'm
going to see these questions haha but
there you have it and I suggest here
that insofar as resources are concerned
that you go to this course in link and
one at a time or depending on your level
go through them and we will be adding
more I've only added the first twelve
and I'll those are those basic and
grammatical concepts that I refer to but
I'll be adding the ones where it's
helping you express yourself you no
doubt possibility and so forth and I
also recommend for someone who is
interested in working on tenses that you
go to this other course in our library
put those Avista I put obviously
everybody knows Google but Google is a
tremendous resource for language
learners
you can put you can look for very
specific or very general resources on
just about any language you're studying
and so I just remind you that that is
often a useful thing to do okay there we
go
the question how to improve of all that
vocab vocabulary comes from engagement
with interesting content it comes from a
context because a word isolated all by
itself if you were to read the
dictionary I think it'd be very
difficult to learn the words from the
dictionary so engage with interesting
content ideally I mean we develop links
because we think it's the best way to
acquire vocabulary and you save words to
a database
they are subsequently highlighted in
yellow which reminds you that you have
seen them you click you see the meaning
again you see it in different context
and slowly it becomes a part of you
you can also flashcard when our
flashcard in my own case I put the
meaning as well as the captured phrase
on the front of the flashcard so to me
it's just more exposure and I split
through them relatively quickly now no
sound no getting out of window DRS which
accent have you adopted for Spanish all
right I spent most of my formative
period in learning Spanish in Spain I
traveled there when I was a student in
France and I've traveled there off and
on holidays so that's what I'm not
comfortable with but I think that
Spanish is pronounced quite clearly like
in Mexico Colombia Venezuela Argentina
has a special sort of Lille to it it
really doesn't matter it depends on your
experience your requirements and so
forth is a lot of masculine or feminine
la is feminine
always always always not every now that
and then a is feminine but 98% but la is
feminine someone can't hear me perfectly
today's this I don't know what I can do
some people hear me some people don't
how do you not mix up Spanish and French
men speaking I don't mix them up I think
again this issue of mixing languages I
think if we acquire our languages
through massive listening reading these
languages become
six in our brain and we transfer our
ourselves over to our spanish-speaking
you know control center or a
french-speaking control center and
there's relatively little little
overflow or overlap if on the other hand
we learn through trying to acquire
certain rules of grammar and studying a
certain list of vocabulary I find that
is a much more tenuous a weak control
over the language so I don't have
because I I focused entirely on on you
know massively on listening and really
yeah occasionally like a language that I
don't speak well like if I'm speaking
Korean I might slide into Japanese
because the brain is looking for a
foreign language and it goes to the
wrong spot but I know from experience
that if I continue my listening and
reading activity with Korea eventually I
won't make that mistake so no questions
did you see this question do you see
this question yes hello what's the verb
okay the verb to be in Spanish we have
this particular situation of said and
this time both means to be now the
explanations that you'll find and by the
way you can google say and start and
you'll find ample explanation and ample
you know examples but in a nutshell
share is to be something that you that
is essentially a part of your identity
of who you are it's permanent whereas
estar indicates a state of being that
might change so I think of the example
there's a you know la Bamba total 30
mile in a door so Capitan
so if Capitan so I'm not a sailor I'm a
captain that's what I am SOI but it's
totally I am happy estoy Sally tomorrow
might be sad but today I'm happy so if
you think of soy Capitan it's totally
that might help remind you of you know
when you go to use the word to be
whether it's a permanent situation or
something that might change can you see
this yes how
have you been learning Spanish what kind
of tools are you using okay I am NOT
studying Spanish now my exposure to
Spanish was when I was students in
France I would go hitchhiking in Spain
in 1964 65 66 I would sit for hours and
hours and hours with everybody called
truck drivers and kind of people will
pick me up and I read because Spanish is
easy to read Spanish is one of these
languages where you can very quickly get
into real meaningful adult material and
I suggest that anyone studying Spanish
should read a lot take advantage of the
fact that it is easy to read and get
into real interesting material as
quickly as possible
how are the Spanish compared to German
to me Spanish is a lot easier because
it's not the German isn't written
phonetically but there's a lot of
letters that are kind of unnecessary
like SCH for sure SH would do based on
my English background you know a the
ëifí Spanish easier more even though
German is meant to be a Germanic
language I find that there is more
vocabulary overlap with Spanish so I
kind of find it easier but German you
know it's all a matter of interesting
content once I found once with German I
stopped trying to study the declension
tables and found interesting content to
listen to and read my German improved
immensely so the key is to find things
of interest to you okay hi your
information was very useful I have a
question all right sir you're good for
feeling done here doesn't percent of
living are basically shows Deutschland
thank you that's from Mike hip heart can
you see my question can you see this
question how do you live how do you
listen all right how do you listen when
you start listening to a new language
it's just noise you can't even tell
where one word ends and the next word
begins so I listen to short 30 seconds
ten for which I have the text and that's
why you think because I can read it I
can look up the words and then I listen
again and I still don't understand
and then I read it and I review the
words that looked up and I understand it
now and then I listen and I select it
and so this process continues and then
I'll take another lesson and another
lesson and after about four or five of
these I find that I'm able to understand
more and more but always I read and I
save words from the text of whatever
content I'm listening to and over time
it's been my experience my ability to
understand what I'm listening to
improves and so initially I'm listening
quite often to the same material five
six seven ten times and as I improve I
listen less often to the same content
because more and more now I'm able to
get into meaningful interesting content
where I'm driven more by my interest in
the content rather than the sort of
desire to to drill the sound entity and
so you gradually become a more and more
sort of content focused listener rather
than listening for sort of specific
words or patterns however you still want
to try to maintain your focus focus on
certain types of vocabulary or
structures that give you difficulty
alright for me as a beginner but there's
no questioner how is the best way to
memorize vocabulary with us Berto and
get restless I don't memorize vocabulary
I never memorize vocabulary I keep
listening and reading I read in link
where I can see the words that I've
looked at before highlighted in yellow
and I've motivated mostly by my interest
in the content so I don't get fronted I
can't wait to get to the next content
item and if if it's of interest to me
you know I struggle through the words
that I don't know looking them up and
adding them to my basic vocabulary
database but I don't get frustrated do
you have any advice on how to use in the
language clicking Spanish and dated open
the people around you currently don't
speak it very difficult very difficult
you know I study Russian or Ukrainian or
Korean here I don't speak it very often
so I say my
first goal is to understand it well sort
of preparing myself for the situation
where I will have the opportunity or the
need to use it if you don't have the
need or the opportunity you have to
create it so inevitably you have to set
up some online discussion with a tutor
whether it be as I talked to you or some
other website or at league to start
using it but if not it's more difficult
to do you have to schedule it you may
have to pay the person and you in fact
even if you don't speak it you can
continue to improve your language
potential your capability in the
language by this process of continuing
to work on your comprehension because
when you do have the opportunity to talk
to someone to me the worst situation is
if I don't understand what they're
saying
I can struggle with what I have to say
and it doesn't bother me and I think
that's another important point when you
start to speak you're going to stumble
you're going to struggle and that's
normal and don't sort of look back and
say gee I didn't do very well and I
couldn't express myself it doesn't
matter
but the worst situation is if you don't
understand what the other person is
saying and that's why I always put a
major emphasis on comprehension and that
is building up my potential building up
my potential to speak the language and
and if I get the opportunity I take
maximum advantage for example there's a
lot of listening and reading of Czech
when I went to Prague I contacted people
there lined up people so that I was
speaking Czech for seven hours a day so
when you get the opportunity take
maximum advantage because in order to
speak well you have to speak a lot but
when you don't have the opportunity
continuing to listen and read is very
good in terms of developing that
potential either got any ideas how to go
about learning the subjunctive mood
learning it naturally by listening and
reading might be extremely hard I guess
all right subjunctive mood I think it's
important to understand the basic
concept is not difficult
basic concept is that where there is
uncertainty or obligation or a number of
other conditions which you can find if
your google of the Spanish subjunctive
when that condition exists the verb will
be in the subjunctive mood so that's the
basic general principle understanding
that principle is not going to help you
use the subjunctive property in order to
use the subjunctive properties you have
to train yourself so that you start
naturally without even thinking about it
coming out with this with the
subjunctive there in mind just like with
any other difficulty in a foreign
language in other words where this
foreign languages has some aspect that
you don't have in your own language
you are only gradually going to improve
or increase your level of accuracy so
you might get it right 10% of the time
and then 20 then 30 and therefore you so
you have to be patient in developing
your accuracy in using the subjunctive
now in order to get better at the
subjunctive you need to first of all
notice if in your listening and reading
so when I'm reading if I have trouble
with subjunctive I would underline it
every instance of the subjunctive or
what I think is their subjective on I
could be wrong you should notice which
words seem to trigger the subjunctive
okay and these are these who are words
that are phrases that you can save a
link for example or underline you know
and then you could go to the lesson that
we're going to put in the link where you
can practice the subjunctive and so you
do this concentrated practice but I
should explain or confess that I never
do exercises where you know answer the
following question and I have to you
know make sure that I use the
subjunctive I never do those but I would
go to the answers section where I would
see ten sentences answered in the
subjunctive and that gives me this
concentrated exposure to examples of the
subjunctive
similarly you can go to those exercises
in the main and practice the subjunctive
and so you have to increase your ability
to know
just these examples of the subjunctive
and you will find gradually that
naturally your accuracy in accuracy and
using the subjunctive will improve I'd
like to know if you feel you are quite
chilly in Spanish yes I think I'm quite
fluent in Spanish I have no trouble
understanding I have no trouble
expressing myself I make mistakes but
fluency doesn't imply perfection fluency
to me is the ability to communicate more
or less comfortably on a wide variety of
subjects while making mistakes while
sometimes not understanding and while
sometimes searching for words and I
provide fluent in Spanish although I
never speak it rarely if I were in spend
you know an evening with Spanish
speakers then my fluency would improve
thank you very much is it possible to
start learning more than one language at
the same time of course it's possible I
have found that difficult to do because
I get so committed to the one language
that I'm studying because it is a it's
an almost emotional commitment don't
underestimate the degree to which you
have to commit yourself to the language
almost emotionally and in terms of the
time you're willing to commit to the
language so trying to do that with two
languages at the same time is difficult
however what you can do is start
learning one new language say 80% of the
time and sort of maintain or continue to
improve in a language where you are
already further along okay what material
did you use for Spanish I mean I read
books spoke to people today I don't do
much in Spanish but I have the I have
for example some podcasts from co-pay
Spanish broadcast case you read the
newspaper my Spanish I worked on you
know many many years ago so I have been
doing much unfinished recently would you
please do a webinar in Japanese yes if
based on the experience here if this is
useful I kind of do similar webinars on
a number of other languages great
presentation thank you I started to use
memorize to learn Spanish words it is
used when I found a lot of the words in
the presentation familiar because of
this what are your thoughts on memory
you know the key thing in language
learning is to do things that you enjoy
doing because if you enjoy doing them
you'll have a good attitude you'll spend
the time the whole experience will be
positive I am NOT a fan of these
dedicated vocabulary learning tools
whether it be memorize and key I can't
remember the names of them but other
people love them so that's fine I I
learned so many words like any language
that I'm learning my vocabularies count
and Link is I mean I'm learning
thousands of words a year I don't know I
checked ukrainian-russian Korea I'm 20
30 40 50 60 thousand words I have
according to our statistics at link if I
were to try to learn those all using
some kind of memorizing system you know
I spend my whole day at it so no I
prefer to spend my time listening and
reading and learning in link and I don't
use memorize but for those people who
enjoy doing it super yeah again I stress
we need so many words in order to be
able to understand the native speaker I
just don't agree with the people who say
with 500 words you can get by yeah you
can say although I want a beer where's
the bathroom
yeah or you'll study sort of what to say
in the bank what to say in a restaurant
and and and when you go to the
restaurant and you say whatever it is
you were told to say you won't
understand what the other person is
saying so I believe in the importance of
vocabulary and I think vocabulary is
best acquired through massive listening
and reading
can I count the 12 tips again all right
now the 12 tips of course had to do with
with the sort of 12 basic concepts in a
language basic grammar concepts remember
I had three groups I had a sort of basic
grammar column the basic concepts the
second group was getting to expressing
yourself and the third group was
triggered words so insofar as the first
group and it would be the same in
Russian Chinese
please German it's thinking people then
second was bird third was what how do
you say what fourth was what kind which
introduces adjective and adverb fifth
was we're including you know
prepositions of place the sixth list to
whom by whom
who's for room etc servant was how H was
how many and introducing quantity and
numbers 9 was which and who which is the
whole relative clause issue 10 was
whichever whenever whatever 11 was when
and in promise tenses basically no I we
hopefully will have a copy of this
webinar which we will put up on YouTube
and promptly we can send a PDF around
for those people who are interested next
do you recommend using language exchange
absolutely whatever you like doing
personally I don't do it because when I
look at the time that I have available
it's difficult for me to schedule a
discussion that's a certain time in the
day whereas if I want to listen I listen
I watch the dishes I listen I'm in the
car I'm listening I want to grab a book
I sit down and read or I want to read on
my iPad so to me I don't use mine we do
change but countless it's one of the
wonders of the internet that people can
find friends in and it's not just for
learning languages if it's to meet
people from different cultures and so
forth I heartily heartily endorse the
idea of language exchange I make use of
the language exchange facility that we
have at link and so therefore I'm not on
some of these other web sites but
there's lots of them just Google
language exchange and you'll find them
okay I may have missed it will Attell
contest available for other languages if
it's a successful yes I hope to develop
the same for other languages what would
it what would be your best advice to
learn any language in the world I mean
everything that I'm saying applies to
any language obviously if the script is
different and you have to begin by
learning the strip because reading is
essential in my opinion and so you know
it's Spanish for an English speaker
Spanish the writing system is not a
problem but
if you have an English speaker or
learning Russian Japanese Chinese
Koreans you have to learn the script or
Arabic Farsi whatever I'm a native
speaker of Japanese shutter in Spanish
in English or Japanese interesting
question interesting question I think
there will be far more resources
available for learning Spanish with
English as the sort of learner language
far more resources done by googling or
whatever it might be on the other hand I
think it all depends on how well you
speak English to what extent English is
this is Takamatsu to what extent you
feel totally confident with English
because I believe that when you're
learning a language contrary to some
people who like the monolingual
dictionary I prefer to use a bilingual
dictionary so if I see the word in the
target language bingo I see a suggestion
of what that word means in my language I
don't want to have to struggle through
some explanation in a language that I
don't you know feel totally confident in
so if you are very confident with your
English I will use English to learn
Spanish if you have any hesitation I
will use Japanese or use a mixture all
right and at which level I don't
understand that we'll be able to
download and watch this webinar yes I'm
considering learning either one which is
either my native languages Cantonese
second language is English I don't see
the first question for that but the
question about which should I learned
always boils down to what are you most
motivated to learn that it's
overwhelmingly going to decide your
success your level of motivation alright
by the way congratulations for your
birthday cue I'm learning Japanese in
Chinese I am learning Japanese and
Chinese harder than Spanish because I'm
learning them and more at the same time
yeah if you learning more than one at
the same time difficult I would focus on
the one you're most motivated to learn
what's your opinion of penciler and
Michel Thomas I am NOT a fan like lots
of people swear by teams for
lots of people swear by Michel common
the advantage of both of those is you
just put it in your you know audio
player and away you go to listen to only
the target language and I because I am
motivated and I'm aware of how much
vocabulary I have to acquire and because
I consider the first goal of language
learning is comprehension that if I have
a solid base in comprehension that
speaking will come so therefore I'm not
so concerned about whether I can produce
the language at an early stage so for
those reasons I'm not such a big fan of
of either Michel Thomas or or pencil but
that's me and there are lots of people
who love those two systems how do you
start to speak to break a barrier I can
write to read but speak is ready to go
yeah learning for four-month per month
is nothing when you start speaking it's
going to be difficult you're going to
stumble you're used to being an adult
speaker in your own language and all of
a sudden you're a child we can't say
anything it's a struggle that's
unfortunately that's part of language
learning and you just have to continue
speaking and not worry about how you
sound or how you do just keep going and
you'll gradually you won't get worse you
can only get better and continue with
the reading and listening do you think
there is any particular spanish-speaking
country that's best to travel to when
you're still try to learn Spanish again
I've only been to Spain I've been to
Spain Mexico and Chile any one of those
streets I don't think that there is a
better country it's just where whatever
your opportunities are and what you're
motivated to do should I learn English
in Spanish together again I kind of
addressed it you know learn the language
that you're most motivated to learn and
I would focus on one at a time
so basically you think the best way to
start learning Spanish nowadays is using
such Internet resources as link all it
also does the Spanish in Spain and Latin
America differ very much okay
I believe that Spanish is one language
where you should read a lot because it's
relatively easy to read I believe that
listening and reading
whether you do it in length or somewhere
else that should be your major point of
emphasis if you're starting from scratch
of course you have to start with simple
material I would go and buy a simple
book the smaller the book the better you
want to cover the grammar many many
times or use some of the resources we
have it makes the quantity of beginner
material that we have in our library I
think is phenomenal so take advantage oh
thank you
compliment what is your opinion of
multiple languages at the same time all
right
again I've dealt with this multiple
language issue I prefer concentrating on
one a language to learn at the same time
as Spanish although some people might
disagree yeah
Portuguese something that's relatively
close because you're learning you know
the grammatical structure has so much
similarity the vocabulary is so similar
that if I were to do two it was I would
take two very similar languages I'm an
intermediate Spanish speaker wanting to
learn French do you recommend that I
begin learning French absolutely if
you're motivated to learn French go
after French put you know 70% of your
effort on French and 30% on Spanish
continues birds I'm wondering about how
to learn reflexive verbs don't know why
you say yeah good we will also put some
drill sentences in there for it's like
the verb how to learn them it's the same
as with any of these other things you
can Google Spanish reflexive verbs
you'll get a bunch of explanations
examples reviews are then and you're
listening and reading try to notice it
and slowly these things will start to
become habit-forming for you in the
future for the next time would be good
to get up a whiteboard you can write on
all right along the lines of my previous
question of which accent you've adopted
have you encountered a pushback from
people wondering if you speak with a
certain accent for example have you had
Americans as southern red white oh yeah
yeah this whole issue of accent I think
it's overdone I think it doesn't matter
insofar as listening to content it
doesn't matter
acquiring vocabulary there are some
differences of vocabulary from country
to country
yes I have occasionally had comments
from people in Latin America saying why
do you speak with Spanish accent
overwhelmingly no people are very happy
simply to communicate with me in Spanish
you know when I was in Mexico I mean
essentially no never no real pushbike
have you a lesson series that is
specifically to tourists to Mexico which
focuses in the language they would use
specific to their travel there are I
don't know we have so much content in
our libraries however I don't know that
that's that meaningful I think because
you can't anticipate what the native
speaker is gonna say to you I would
still favor and I always favor staying
you know trying to learn the language
generally building up my overall level
in the language rather than trying to
nail down some you know specific
dialogue that I might help me not sure
I've lost interest or my life is too
busy but something has happened to my
desire to learn Spanish I was headed
toward the advanced level or certain
you're done okay so a person has lost
interest what can I say
find something of interest you don't
have to love the whole language you
don't have to love everything about the
culture this was I found I very much
focus on content of interest if I'm
listening I focus on voices that I like
I try to find something that's
interesting is it hard with any speaker
once you don't have an English whether
the gender is difficult every language
has stuff that we don't have in our own
language and those things are difficult
and it just takes time to get used to it
yes of all the Spanish books that you've
read which book was your favorite who
has the best experience with you know I
going from memory but there was a book
by a Basque writer on nationalism called
el Bosque or the scenario which I found
very interesting and la sombra de viento
if I read up on that I read recently I
can't remember
I enjoy whatever we did you know Spanish
with the French yes you get confused
differences between French and Spanish
no should I start reading this thing
attack and when I study Spanish you
needn't
besides they are there many other rules
of pronunciation Spanish yeah Google
Spanish pronunciation do you find
helpful in our language by listening to
the news in that language with that
dependent even if it depends on my
ability to understand the news because
it's important to listen to things that
you also understand I have all right
this person says they spent three hours
a week I mean whatever time you can
spend is good you're always going to
have difficulty and you'll just
gradually improve I've been getting
impatient with beginning Spanish 20 reps
done eg advanced text in French how do
you establish a routine when beginning a
new language go to link take some of the
beginning material there and very
quickly move to the more interesting
material particularly a link where you
can look up the words you don't know
very quickly we can graduate to
particularly someone who has learned
French to an advanced level and this is
Kevin Martin you can move up to
interesting material very very quickly
what do you think of a duolingo not for
me because you know what to me it's just
too limited here are lessons don't
repress tried to Steve might be
negatives you watch it religiously
okay I want Lubitsch st today but very
nice informative webinar and blah blah
blah understand 80% when I listen and
read but only 25% when I listen yeah
this is always going to be the case you
have to continue listening it's
gradually believe it or not it gets
better I'm not that famous Korean right
now I listen and read hardest at 80%
when I go away and I only listen I
understand 20 30 depending on whether
I'm able to grab that sort of context or
not how does your program different from
rosetta stone Laura tried it's
completely different that's all I can
say all right mmm no how do I not forget
I don't forget because I have learned it
through a process of massive input and
that learning process ensures that the
language stays with you you may forget
initially but that you quickly relearn
and then
language is with you even stronger than
before French do a webinar in French or
about French but in either case yes I
can just intend there alright
I'm only interest in football in other
words better expand your range of
interest Steve creates get importante
preserve those are goats that they're
pretty good no I am NOT a big fan of
learning slang or our goal I think that
comes later it is very difficult to use
it
but if it comes up in your reading of
course you're going to try and learn it
but try not to those use slang material
you are very comfortable in the language
Steve for me creating is the most boring
part especially when I announced that we
Spanish a month ago there's a lot of new
words to learn and not that many Slovak
make use and have to look up all my
words yeah you got to go through the
process of saving lives it's the most
important activity of a saving links if
there aren't many Slovak users go to
English that's all I can say
looking forward could you please say
something in Russian yeah my boob EE
polski okay just to cut up there we go
say some things in Russian what tips
would you give someone trying to get
from an interview lever to an advanced
level massive listening reading and
speak when you get the chance
how do not forget languages listen and
read read a book every now and again are
you going to learn some polish I'm
dabbling in Polish but I'm trying to get
this Korean nailed down polish is going
to be fun because it's remarkably
similar to Ukrainian if the script of a
language is different how would you
recommend learning it yeah learning the
kana you just got to do it Google like I
had I did it so many years ago I have no
advice when with a PDF for the 12 core
patterns will be sent to you yes FSI to
me is too boring
thanks for answering my questions blah
blah blah
yeah I have a question how not to forget
it covered SML is a fine it's a source
of content no not much better than in my
opinion than others somewhat expensive
depends some are better than others if
you have to give only one piece of rice
what would that be try to enjoy your
learning
I will do whatever German yes I will you
often talk about listening listening
resources I mean start with our library
at Linc and there's lots of other
resources there as well on our on our
import page and you can go there and
import material or just study it
how many words do we this is going to be
the last question how many words do we
have to know to speak fluently depends
on the language you know you have
inflected languages like Slavic
languages where the word count would be
higher but I think that it's somewhere
around 10,000 you know photography Louis
a large number but the key point is to
continue enjoyably listening and reading
speaking whenever you can not worrying
about where you make mistakes and and
trying to enjoy it at the whole process
so thank you very much I'm going to stop
there and have a glass of water and I
hope that this has been enjoyable for
you thank you for listening and I'm
going to shut this down now